we
all have stories connected to a piece of
clothing
it's not just a shirt anymore
[Music]
it's actually like humming with energy
in fifth grade i found this t-shirt it
was responsible for what i turned into
i put in my first pair of heels i was
like
oh yeah this is who she is
clothing is an art form
it is about expression i can be a
crossing guard by day
and a ninja by night
that outfit it was an active rebellion
of defiance
i wasn't going to let people bully me
into being
normal i am not normal
please don't misconscrute me
once you go to jail your whole identity
is gone
so we're gonna go pick up some clothing
all right from the moment you put it on
you already start feeling different
i'm a free man with the clothes i got on
i looked in the mirror
and i liked what i saw
this dress he bought it for me before he
passed away
i put it on i said sally do you see it
still fits
nasa said okay you can bring one shirt
from home
and that's when i decided that's the
shirt i'm taking reminded me that
dreams do come true what you wear speaks
volumes
so much about who we are
is stitched into the fabrics that we
wear every day
if i went back and said hey little you
this t-shirt would completely change
your life
i would have said of course see you
there
i hate clothes it's so much better being
totally naked
[Music]
my god that's impossible
we were on that plane when it landed we
watched that plane explode
it sounds insane but i can feel the tail
fin
beckoning me who did you see
you're one of us sometimes i see visions
i'm supposed to help her
surviving the death they gave me a
do-over something
inexplicable is happening i think we
died on that flight
how much are you willing to sacrifice to
get to the truth
ready
welcome to eureka
look when i left svu
i know i didn't handle that well he
didn't handle it at all
we worked side by side for 10 years man
know how so much time has passed that
you you can't reach out
days turn into months turn into years
and
i just kept waiting for the right moment
phil can seven is dead
[Music]
find judy ken seven and he's named bird
girl as the next ceo of seven and seven
paging burger here to save the company
you're not supposed to stand on the
table she's gonna have to make that
tough choices
can't we be post not fighting yes we
can't
not totally but she's not going in alone
she's got a team
[Music]
the only thing more dangerous than
everyday life is corporate life
thanks for unlocking it watch the series
premiere of bird girl
sunday april 4th at midnight
on adult swim not today toilet
not today mom i need the new lebron
james's stop calling them lebron james's
they're just called lebrons
we're in high school now we can't be
losers anymore
why did you eat the lunch i made you it
was lamb stew
do you ever eat just regular american
food like peanut butter sandwiches with
the crust cut off
wait a minute can you get that it's my
date isn't the whole point of being a
mom that you don't have a life anymore
and it's all about the children
nope razzle dazzle never go i promised
mom i would babysit the crap out of you
now get on your jammies put on a better
attitude
and let's spend some quality time
together
you kids in your screens
i didn't realize you were persian i'm
not like so
different i just have olive skin cause
i'm a kayak
would it be okay if we just try to blend
in more when we're in public can you
hook me up with that wi-fi password
we're enjoying each other's company
right now chad
king i feel like that depends on who you
ask
[Music]
right
to truly master kung fu you must find
peace peace with your family
peace and my family don't really go
together
golden child's back baby i don't think
i'm gonna go to law school anymore
walk in like a boss with my money yeah
you've been training since you got back
does fighting gangsters count
thanks for the assist you're a kung fu
butt-kicking hero
she's in trouble i stepped in stepped in
more like punch i'd live for this stuff
you took down an army by yourself
you basically walked on air it was
physics
this is what i meant to do kung fu
new series starts wednesday april 7th
free next day only on the cw
app
[Music]
pretty nice huh
[Music]
you couldn't imagine a nicer place to
live i wish i was home i wish i was back
there
with the things i've been
knowing
this home is ours
this is how it begins with one family
they came from someplace worse we'll
have to make this place
worse what's worse and worse
heard them folks in compton straight up
evil man
[ __ ] this
there's something bad in this house
i don't like it we got our eyes on you
we do this till it gets done
live in here
think of home
three years ago everyone at the touch
woke up
with a power attached are rewriting the
rules of reality
i want them under control
[Applause]
even if it requires a bloodletting
i will cut your face to a mess
you know the touch yes they have weird
deformities and afflictions
they're unhappy well whatever they are
i think they're a gold mine
you know what a better world could be
like is that the mission you were going
on about
yes i do have a mission and i'm not cut
out for it
but it matters
there's a harmony to our world that's
worth preserving
the touched are not a threat yet you
seem determined to prove that they are
the church the purists they're a danger
to us
we have enemies we don't know about yet
oops
i am here for a reason our first
response cannot be hate we'll be lined
up in the streets
you want the wicked punished and the
good protected
you often engage in public violence
i know where i am in a fight because i
see glimpses of the future
something happened
it's not fun watching you throw yourself
a dng like you think it's gonna propose
could be fun
there's savagery chaos
attached to the protection and i need
information
about why we're here and what we're
meant to do next
we're taking a terrible risk the future
of the world depends on what i'm doing
the future of the world depends on the
present
attached are part of something much
bigger
[Music]
coaches here they're expected to be
role models do not screw this up
coach marvin korn is going from the ncaa
to some fancy high school
personally i think it's all a big
mistake but i'm prepared to make the
best of it
holly barrett assistant coach marvin
korn any advice
these girls going to lead the world
someday fall in
some of them can be a bit much i'm sorry
you chewing gum
this is westbrook we won't respond to my
wire or the highway
it's my job to help you improve
i'm going to teach you my system of
basketball from the ground up smaller
steps but faster
is the whistle really necessary yes it
really is
okay then i figured it'd be rough but
this is next level if we all just quit
they fire him i think he wants to be a
good person
when they said you were coming that
meant something i was excited
all i care about is basketball my dad
he sees me playing either at stanford or
ucla it's about making my father proud
after watching you play i truly believe
that we could do something special or
just getting started
oh that'd be a good boomerang do it
again
you're connecting with these girls no
stop it
i just wanted to say thank you for
caring
john f kennedy said we do this not
because it is easy
but because it is hard that was about
the moon
if you try your very best
and you have the potential to be great
let's go win a basketball game
we've all lost so much jack
vanessa we need to end it once and for
all
the past has altered
together we can stop the rise of the
dark one
he was like you want to know about the
first one
it took me a minute to realize he's
confessing
sam little is the most prolific
serial killer in american history
it's mind-boggling he would have never
gained that title had the system dealt
with him correctly
i don't feel that she was important
enough
to investigate he was used to
getting away with it and getting away
with it it's shocking
they failed me they failed every woman
after me
that was killed i started reaching out
to him to bring
justice to these cold cases and restore
the names
of these victims he did these drawings
for me i'm determined to help identify
them that's my job
how many women have you killed
i was killing for pleasure
i have access to him so my deal with the
devil
is you will not die alone if you
tell me the truth if you weren't locked
up i'd probably be dead by now
i'm richard what's your name mayor
give it up for miss lady hawk herself
why didn't they call you lainey hawk i
made a shot in a basketball game
25 years ago you think you're a hero
i love it look at that it must have been
some shot
most places no around here
yeah what do you do mayor i'm a
detective
a detective you don't have any bodies
hidden under your porch do you
uh not yet no
[Music]
the easttown police department received
a call reporting a dead body
in cretum get that son of a creek
you did this cause if you don't i'll
kill him myself
[Applause]
tell me about your father he was my best
friend
he passed away when i was 13. he was a
detective
at least you still got your mother oh we
can't stand each other
i can feel it happening again
this expectation from people to be
something i don't think i'm good enough
to be
mayor i know what you've been through
and i know you're worth saving
the ground is just falling out beneath
you mom we don't know what's gonna
happen all right
go back to the file dig deep recommit
yourself
[Music]
doing something great is overrated
people expect that from you
all the time
the italians have had me on the run for
three solid months
but this is a game of chess
i got my pieces in position and i'm
putting a greed in check
it's time to take all them back
johnson don't control harlow who's gonna
be dead by the end of the day
you can help me get the big fish
and eliminate the competition
my entire purpose is to spread the word
of islam without that who am i
you're me for more like you think i need
you to stand up for me
swear to god things ain't going bumpy
has turned into a liability
now is not the time for black men to
turn on each other
it's the siege the corsicans the french
connection i'm willing to fight them
tooth and nail for every inch of harlem
new world is here my brothers
[Music]
someone doesn't have to be out in the
woods too long to
feel like i might not belong here and
something is going to take me out
i've been a journalist for about 25
years embedding with street gangs
going undercovers in neo-nazi skinhead
and i'm going to tell you the craziest
story i've ever heard i was working on a
cannabis farm up to northern california
i remember a guy telling me about three
bodies
torn to pieces he said a bigfoot killed
those guys
a bigfoot murdered three guys on a dope
farm
[Music]
there's always been rumors of legendary
violence
the story of sasquatcher of man-like
monsters has been with us from the very
beginning
there's a belief in supernatural forces
that runs deeper
up here than most places
you believe that sasquatch can teleport
that no
yes you do no i do not you do do not go
there
the emerald triangle is famous worldwide
for producing cannabis plants
is just the best in the world people
came here to get
rich quick they don't want outsiders up
there
the rate of missing persons cases is the
highest in the united states
by far old-time cannabis schools for
when they sit down and talk to me but
there's no way they're ever going to go
on camera
many people have been killed up there
and never found
i'm venturing into dangerous territory
with all these hippies listening to the
grateful dead but packing an ar-15
we probably have more bodies than we
could even count that's pretty bad
tell me about the crime that your son
witnessed i really can't talk about that
people pass through here and they just
see how beautiful it is
they have no idea the [ __ ] that goes on
in this area
as scary as some of these stories are we
still want to figure it out
people are afraid of the unknown the
evidence convinces me that sasquatch is
dangerous
it scared the crap out of me i don't
know if i believe in bigfoot
but i sure as hell believe there are
monsters among us
400 years ago my patriarchal ancestor
lawrence rutherford found our town
anyone see the resemblance i definitely
see it it's in the jaw
shoulders through the chest and probably
some other places
okay thank you i am the steward of my
family's legacy that will resonate
throughout history and you have a museum
you're gonna get yours too
this is a ginormous casino but nobody
wants to help my cultural center the
only native artifacts in here
are those bangs you seem smart i'm
guessing lots of college
not ivy league but so close it drives
you crazy
northwestern nathan i'm calling to
request a response to mayor chisenhall's
decision to move big larry i'm sorry
what
the problem is not big larry it's the
road
this is the fifth time someone's crashed
into that statute it's a public safety
issue
it's history deirdre you can't change
history unless you have a time machine
and you don't because if you did you'd
go back and tell yourself not to buy
that blazer
[Music]
this town has forgotten how to honor
their ancestors we focus on the problems
that are actually important big larry's
important
more important than the opioid crisis
apples and oranges carla
there's something happening in that town
this is a story
about stories damn the
podcasting voice is very manipulative
there's so much drama let's uh leave
them
okay no but i'm not done telling these
people why they're wrong and stupid
this is why it's not worth being friends
with white people
you're safe now
tell me what happened in the phone
saved you you won't believe me
but this was a sun summoner
is this true
can you summon light
she's real
[Music]
our enemies are threatened by your mere
existence
the whole world will be after you the
prize
is one million krueger
bring me a lena star card am i a
prisoner
one of rafki is until you and i enter
the fold
and destroy it from within
so no pressure
everyone is looking at me like i'm the
answer
i bring the light
again
the only thing more powerful than you or
me
the two of us together
good girl now the work begins
if it goes wrong i'll find my way back
to you
how many bullets do you have not enough
she'll realize she has only one equal
that i know others like us and there
never will be
you have no idea how much larger a role
you have to play
[Music]
ms osborne if you were returned to
gilead
would you be subject to danger of
torture
a risk to your life or a risk of cruel
and unusual treatment or punishment
i'm looking for june osborne you're
better off without her
everyone that helps her ends up on the
wall she has eluded your soldiers for 19
days
find her and bring her to me
[Music]
do you have some secret brilliant plan i
made a promise to hurt them
the way we heard this morning a plane
left gilead and landed had pearson
there were 86 children on board this
will start a war
we came here to fight no you came here
to fight
you can't save her you understand that
right
some women don't want to be saved
we're the ones we've been waiting for
[Music]
she's public enemy number one in gilead
she's not gonna last another week here
perhaps she's fulfilled her purpose and
it's time to move
on i can't i gotta find her
run i'm gonna give up
how can i face him everything that has
happened to her is because of
me she chose to stay in gilead
i can't ask god for something that she
didn't want
everything has changed the world is
tilted on its axes
freedom agrees with you we are not free
you have destroyed my life
my family my friends
my country
[Music]
i ask for justice
dad why are you doing this to us
oh is that such a big secret
because we have a problem
what kind the problem you know the kind
of problem
that you think okay first glance that
looks pretty bad
the kids could get hurt they're not
going to get hurt
they're with us that's what i'm worried
about
if i just sit down and think about it
i might be able to figure a way out of
it
we don't have that kind of problem
we make the move and we start again
this is going to be an adventure
i'm scared
absolutely if it didn't feel that way
it wouldn't be an adventure
we need to go come on
you